all right so let's start with the bag of
sugar what does this bag of sugar weigh
it weighs one kilogram oh well you see
there's the critical point about it
because of course it doesn't actually
weigh one kilogram at all what it
actually weighs is 9.81 newtons
because weight is actually a force it's
not what you've just quoted is the mass
of this bag of sugar and this is one of
those things that um scientists you know
who are a bit anal attentive about these
kinds of things like to try and one-up
the for the layman by saying of course
weight's really a force
and you just did which i yes i just did
but what i re i mean what i really want
to say in this video is that actually it
doesn't matter whether you say its
weight is a kilogram or its weight is
9.81 newtons
and actually the fact it doesn't matter
is the interesting thing
really mass is associated with two
completely different things one is the
mass that comes into newton's second law
false equals mass times acceleration
which is you know how hard it is to make
something accelerate and the more
massive it is the harder it is you know
you have to push about a one kilogram
bag of sugar twice as hard to accelerate
the particular weight as you have to
push a 500 gram bag of wholemeal bread
mix
give or take i mean in this case this is
the complicating factor this is friction
against the table and so on but if you
ignore all the friction effects and
those kinds of things it's still harder
to push something which has a higher
mass than something which has a lower
mass so that's one kind of mass
the other kind of mass is to do with
gravity that actually when you have a
massive object it exerts a gravitational
pull on other things and that's another
of newton's laws is the law of gravity
which says that there is this universal
force law between two different objects
and in this case it's the force between
a bag of sugar and the earth and the bag
of sugar and the earth are
gravitationally attracting one another
and that's why when you drop it it falls
to the ground
um and in some sense these are two
completely different things right one's
to do with how hard it is to make
something move fast and the others to do
with the pool of gravity which is you
know not really the same physics at all
the fact that they are seem to be the
same thing um has an interesting
consequence and for that i'm gonna have
to do the equations the first kind of
mass we were talking about is the one
that comes into newton's famous equation
force
is equal to mass
times acceleration newton's second law
even i know that one okay the other one
is the pull of gravity between two
masses is the force of gravity between
them is equal to the universal
gravitational constant
times the mass of the first thing
times the mass of the second thing
divided by the distance between them
squared so the interesting thing that
happens is when you put these two
equations together so in terms of our
bag of sugar
if we drop it under gravity it
accelerates downwards okay and the rate
at which it accelerates downwards is
given by this force is equal to mass
times acceleration where the force is
the full of gravity so now we've
combined these two things together this
is an acceleration which is being caused
by a force the force is that of gravity
so let's combine these two equations
together
we now have that the force of gravity on
that bag of sugar is g times well the
first mass in this case is the mass of
the earth times the mass of the bag of
sugar let's call that little m divided
by divided by the radius of the earth
squared
and that is going to be equal to
the mass of the bag of sugar
times the rate at which it accelerates
but the interesting thing about this
equation is we've now got that mass of
the bag of sugar on both sides of the
equation which means we can just divide
through by it and make it go away and
this is saying that the rate at which
something accelerates under the force of
gravity doesn't depend any longer on the
mass of the object this is a very famous
experiment that's been done since time
immemorial you drop a heavy object and a
light object and as long as you can get
away from air resistance and those kinds
of things they'll actually both
accelerate at the same rate this is our
leaning tower
galileo leaning tower of pisa
um they did it on the moon which was
kind of an entertaining place to do it
because they don't have to worry about
air resistance with a feather and a
hammer i think they used on the moon
how about that this equivalence between
these two kinds of mass is a thing
called the equivalence principle the
fact that the the mass that's associated
with how hard you have to push something
to accelerate it and the mass that's
associated between the pull of gravity
between two things uh is this thing
called the equivalence principle and
indeed one of the ways you can quite
accurately test the equivalence
principle is by doing quite clever
subtle experiments basically just
involving dropping weight and usually do
it in a vacuum to get away from air
resistance effects and seeing what rate
they accelerate at and it's been
demonstrated to incredibly high levels
of precision now that actually these two
masses really are one and the same thing
and the interesting thing is it doesn't
matter what the thing's made of so you
know if you drop
a kilogram of
sugar or a kilogram of flour or a
kilogram of anything else
you'll always see the same effects and
there's the same equivalent so it's
nothing to do with what the stuff's made
of it's some very fundamental law that
says that somehow the masses associated
with the force of gravity and the mass
that's associated with acceleration are
very intimately related to one another
so now we have to go to einstein so this
is after he's developed special
relativity in the early part of the 20th
century where which is actually it
deliberately rules out acceleration it's
just to do with inertial reference
frames things moving at uniform speeds
uniform velocities so they keep moving
in a straight line at a constant speed
um but obviously einstein was interested
in going beyond this and so started
thinking about what happens if things
accelerate in special relativity he made
this kind of great leap that says
actually the laws of physics are going
to be the same if you're in a sealed box
you can't tell whether the seal box is
stationary or whether it's moving at a
constant speed there's no experiment you
could do that would allow you to
distinguish between those two things so
we started thinking maybe there's
something very fundamental about this
association between
the mass that's to do with how hard it
is to make things accelerate and the
masses to do with the force of gravity
and again he came up with a rather
similar kind of experiment that says a
thought experiment that says
if you put somebody in a sealed box
they can't tell if they're pulled
towards the floor they can't tell if
they're being pulled towards the floor
because there's a pull of gravity
pulling towards the floor or if they're
being pulled towards the floor because
the box is accelerating upwards so it's
very much the same kind of thing as he'd
done before but now in a very different
regime and you can see that's tying
together these two kinds of forces
because one's an accelerating frame so
that's clearly the mass is going to be
to do with
acceleration and those kinds of things
how hard it is to make things move
inertia
it's inertia yeah it's sort of yeah it's
how resistant things are to being made
to move um and the others to do with
gravity and uh and you know everyone
who's ever stood in a lift an elevator
has experienced this right when the
thing shoots upwards when it accelerates
upwards you feel heavier and sure you
know when it slows down again you feel
lighter and so it's very much it's just
that effect and of course the this thing
that that all your objects will
accelerate at the same rate under the
pull of gravity
follows very directly from that so if
you do a picture of what's going on so
his idea was you can't distinguish
between
whether you're standing in a box
and the box is accelerating upwards
you're pushed to the floor because the
thing's accelerating upwards or if
you're standing in the same kind of box
and there's just a gravitational pull
pulling everything downwards okay and
his his idea was basically well maybe
these are fundamentally
indistinguishable things and of course
our previous experiment then works very
naturally so let's think about this uh
this box and let's not accelerate it to
start with let's just have it standing
you know in in empty space so it's just
a spacecraft or something like that it's
just sitting there and you've got a
couple of weights a little weight and a
big weight
and you let them go at the same time and
of course if you're in floating in free
space with no gravity no acceleration
they'll just stay there right they won't
go anywhere they're just going to float
around in space
next to you now if we introduce this
acceleration what's going to happen is
the box is going to accelerate
and so basically the floor is going to
come up to meet your two weights and of
course because it's the floor that's
moving upwards rather than the weights
moving downwards in that case they're
both going to hit the floor at the same
time
and so if this equivalence is absolutely
is actually true
then in the case where you're just in a
gravitational field and you do the same
experiment you have to get the same
result otherwise you'd be able to tell
which whether you're in a gravitational
field or whether you're accelerating
which means in a gravitational uniform
gravitational field the two have to hit
the ground at the same time and it was
so it was
from this equivalence principle on the
fact that it sort of relates to this
equivalence between an accelerating
reference frame in a gravitational field
that's what led einstein to the entire
theory of general relativity that's what
genius is about right it's being the
first person to point out the obvious
and that's really what einstein did in
this case i said because you know people
i mean i guess the idea was there right
though you know what if i mean something
which accelerates i suddenly feel
heavier that wasn't used to anyone right
because anyone who's ever you know been
in the lift knows that kind of feeling
einstein's
leap was to say has he done before in
special relativity was to say maybe
that's more than just an impression
right maybe that's a fundamental law of
the universe that says that actually
these two things really are equivalent
to each other
and you really there is no experiment
you could imagine doing that would tell
the difference between whether you're in
an accelerating box or whether you're in
a box which is stationary but sitting in
a gravitational field
so what you're saying here is the
special property that mass brings to the
party when we when we're talking about
inertia it's like
reluctance to move
is exactly the same as what it brings to
the party when it starts interacting in
gravitational fields yeah at least
within a constant of proportionality
which you can always hide in that big g
but they're basically measuring the same
quantity and that equivalence really
just follows through into this
equivalence which then leads to the
whole of general relativity how could it
be otherwise of course of course it can
only bring what it is it has nothing but
its mass but you could imagine in some
other universe you could have a bag of
sugar which exerted you know an enormous
gravitational field but just weighed a
kilogram you know so i could push it
around but it had a very strong
gravitational pull and a bag of flour
could have a different gravitational
pull
for the same mass there's no reason
unless you know until you start getting
into all this there's no reason why the
mass you associate with inertia with how
hard it is to push something around and
the mass you associate with
gravitational pull or something have to
be the same thing
well if some smart alec scientist starts
trying to tell you oh no that's not the
weight that's the mass or that's not the
mass that's the way then you're you can
tell them look you know it really
doesn't matter and actually it's some
very fundamental principle of physics
that says it doesn't matter